then i think it's pretty dope
there's a decision to
i want to edgy i want to edgy up a world
that's soft right
and when i think about
south park those guys and what they did
and
the
reason behind it the goal
tackling things being edgy saying the
[ __ ] that a a cartoon character isn't
supposed to say how do we how do we make
this the thing how do we create this
wave and i remember when it started to
kind of pick up right like this thing
started to it started to pick up and
there was a couple of people that were
doing it right and i remember a beatles
and butthead era yeah oh yeah the whole
thing about the beavers and butthead was
what are they going to say yeah yeah
what are they going to say yeah that
that show was under i mean not
underratedly i think at this point
people do
acknowledge it for how
stealthily groundbreaking it really was
you know it really was
it was really something that you look at
those things like like
what and who acts as your
um
you know you're you're who are who are
your
door openers who who do you feel
made it easier for you to come in
and and have the success that you're
having who started it who gave you the
thing that was like oh [ __ ] that's yeah
that's possible you mean just just
looking at the industry from afar yeah i
mean you know again not to sound like a
broken record i mean i you know the
simpsons changed the playing field so i
don't think i could have pitched family
guy and obviously later king of the hill
i don't think i could have pitched that
show
if that complete reset of that industry
had not taken before you was king of the
hill
king of the hill was
you know when i came to fox to pitch
family guy king of the hill was sort of
just getting i'm saying they weren't it
wasn't like a long time no it was it was
pretty it was okay it was pretty new but
this is when fox was also realizing oh
[ __ ]
yeah we we got something in this
animation yeah and that's i mean look
not you know again i i'm from the
northeast we downplay
if
you're from the northeast you're the
person who like you can be served like a
salad at a restaurant with a dog [ __ ] on
it and you'll go i'm so sorry i'm sorry
is there any way can this guy anyway get
another you take the dog [ __ ] off yeah
yeah you take the dogs there you blame
you feel like sometimes yes okay um and
not to downplay the fact that yes i did
bust my ass i worked really hard it was
also
timing was a little bit
in play there yeah i mean i i was
pitching family guy at exactly the time
that everybody wanted animation i mean
that was all anyone was buying it was it
was the simpsons that just exploded king
of the hill was doing great
everybody wanted animation so i i happen
to be
selling exactly what they were buying
but you with the the characters the
voices and and everything as well i mean
this is
this is a part of the the [ __ ] talent
to me that that's mind-blowing because
when you're part of the creative you're
part of the idea the the writing etc but
then you also you also are
talent
this is where it gets a little scary for
me yeah yeah it's i mean
you know again part of that was
i i'd done voices and impressions since
i was a kid okay um it's it's
interesting because i've talked with
actors
who i'm i'm always in awe of actors who
can go on camera and do something you
know take such command of a scene
um and who say boy voiceover that must
be hard and it's like it's god it's
really not it to me it's not it's it's
it's you know what you guys do on camera
but you know headlining a movie that's
that's tough but this talent of
character and the ability to switch in
and out of characters this is something
that you had when you were younger yeah
and is it from somebody else or just
this is i i think i mean the only thing
i can connect it to is that my parents
were very musical my whole family was
very musical there's there's a
you know the the ear was sort of a a
part of everything that that they did
one i mean it possibly that possibly
developed
in part because of the fact that when i
was a kid
i was desperately need of glasses and
nobody knew it until i was about four
so i would be in nursery school sitting
in front of the record player
and being completely anti-social i
wasn't interested in conversing with
anybody i wasn't interested in
interacting with people okay i just
wanted to listen to the record player
and i thought my god this kid's like you
know what is he like a future serial
killer he just doesn't want to be around
and they realized oh he can't see [ __ ]
oh he he like he has he's struggling
with vision yeah he can't see anything
so once they figured that out
then i became the gregarious outgoing
person that i am
[Music]
you